e oggi cerco di raccontarvi una storia
in breve i due mondi delle royalty cosa
significa due mondi e le royalty in un
mondo noi abbiamo i negozi di dischi
gli store online spotify i vinili
nell'altro mondo abbiamo il mondo degli
utilizzatori professionisti quegli
utilizzatori che pagano che sono
organizzati degli eventi magari e che
pagano i monopolisti la sia in italia
per utilizzare musica per scopi
professionali sono due mondi
completamente separati voi conoscete
bene il mondo dei dischi dei negozi
online
quello che vedete spesso sulla carta
stampata ma c'è una particolarità che
differenzia in maniera netta questi
mercati questi due mondi uno è libero
mercato e l'altro è un mercato in
monopolio in quasi tutta europa
quindi da una parte abbiamo un mercato
in cui le persone lottano per emergere
lottano per offrire un servizio migliore
e dall'altra parte invece abbiamo delle
grosse società nazionali che godono di
privilegi monopolisti vediamo un po se
ha senso questa divisione vediamo prima
di tutto la grandezza di questo mercato
il mercato dei monopolisti che un
mercato che non leggete mai sulla stampa
ed è un mercato molto grande e parliamo
di 5 miliardi in europa un flusso di
denaro gestito da monopolisti ogni
nazione il suo monopolio e vedremo
perché quindi un mercato molto per far
per darvi un'idea il mercato della
musica di sottofondo c'è quella musica
che voi ascoltate al supermercato mentre
fate spesa e un mercato da un miliardo
di euro in europa e lo stesso valore più
o meno del mercato dell'hiv
quindi pensate che flusso di soldi
gestito da monopolisti
cerchiamo di capire che cosa fanno
questi monopolisti ogni volta
che un utilizzatore professionale paga
una royalty al monopolio questo
monopolio ripartisce agli aventi diritto
che di fatto sono iscritti al monopolio
già questo è strano sono monopoli ma
l'iscrizione è facoltativa un autore un
editore non è obbligato a scriversi alla
siae è facoltativa all'iscrizione
quindi noi abbiamo un monopolio che
incassa di diritto dall'utilizzatore e
che ripartisce ai propri aventi diritto
che sono iscritti
oggi mi hanno raccontato che c'è un
esibizione qui alla fine e
quell'esibizione giustamente è stata
pagata sia e per quegli otto minuti di
esibizione ed è pagata al monopolista
cerchiamo di capire meglio questi
monopolistiche fanno l'iscrizione di
monopolio come dicevo è facoltativa ma
di fatto è l'unica scelta perché se è
vero che è facoltativa ma se io voglio
essere pagato per la mia performance che
è stata utilizzata da un utilizzatore
professionale di fatto devo essere
iscritto al monopolio se no chi mi paga
e la cosa interessante è che
l'iscrizione a questo monopolio non è
gratuita ea pagamento e il 60 per cento
degli iscritti a questo monopolio non
recupera neanche la tassa di iscrizione
annuale cioè io pago una tassa
d'iscrizione pago 100 120 euro e alla
fine dell'anno non ho recuperato neanche
quei 100 120 euro a questo monopolio che
di fatto è l'unica mia possibilità per
diciamo gestire le mie royalties
ma la cosa più incredibile è che
l'italia questo monopolio è
un'associazione di autori editori ma il
voto è per cento
cosa significa il voto per cento
significa che più si ricco più il tuo
voto vale più sei ricco più il tuo voto
vale e da statuto non è una cosa così e
da statuto
quindi le regole di questo monopolio le
regole di ripartizione di questo
monopolio sono decisi da chi è più ricco
ora vediamo un attimo che cosa succede
in un mercato in cui ci sono 1 poli voi
sapete bene che di solito il monopolio
porta in efficienza ma in questo mercato
hanno veramente esagerato secondo me
perché vediamo un po che cosa succede
per gli aventi diritto
prima di tutto la ripartizione delle
royalties che vengono incassate non è
una ripartizione analitica cioè non si
paga secondo ciò che è stato
effettivamente suonato ma si paga
secondo le regole decise dal consiglio
di gestione del monopolio cioè quei
ricchi che avevano deciso per tutti gli
associati
quindi se per esempio un supermercato
qua dietro paga mille euro al
monopolista il monopolista non chiede al
supermercato che cosa viene suonato ma
ripartisce con le royalties e cioè i
compensi di autori editori parliamo di
compensi gli autori editori i soldi di
autori editori li ripartisce a chi
desidera e non a chi è stato
effettivamente suonato e soprattutto le
ripartisce con una lentezza incredibile
poi pensate che il tempo standard per
pagare un autore editore che è stato
suonato sono circa 18 mesi cioè voi
avete pagato quest'esibizione 8 minuti
alla fine
gli aventi diritto di quei brani
riceveranno questi soldi che voi avete
pagato 180 euro francese c'è tra 18 mesi
se va bene 18 mesi voi accettereste di
fare un lavoro essere pagati dopo 18
mesi ma le cose più incredibili non
finiscono qua dopo che tu hai ricevuto
questi soldi dopo 18 mesi non hai
nessuna possibilità di andare a capire
perché le ricevuti perché non c'è
tracciabilità non c'è trasparenza e non
c'è account online
cioè tu ricevi questo assegno 50 euro
dalla televisione o dalle esibizioni
pubbliche ma non puoi veramente risalire
al perché queste 50 euro sono state
guadagnate e se non può risalire se non
c'è tracciabilità non c'è trasparenza
c'è una nube nera intorno alla tua
conoscenza e quindi se ignorante
l'unica cosa che puoi fare è lamentarti
ma non puoi fare veramente qualcosa se
c'è una nube nera non sai cosa hai
guadagnato o cosa non hai guadagnato
e poi vi lascio a dire vi lascio
immaginare che gli utilizzatori che
pagano si lamentano ovviamente perché il
monopolista non pensa agli utilizzatori
quindi pagamenti difficili pagamenti
complicati e la cosa più brutta è che il
pagamento è percepito come una tassa
quando voi avete pagato 180 euro oggi
pomeriggio per questa esibizione non lo
avete pensato come un pagamento agli
autori dei brani che sono stati suonati
e che saranno suonati e quindi come una
cosa bella ma è stata percepita come una
tassa e questa è la cosa più brutta in
assoluto perché trasformiamo un giusto
pagamento un giusto compenso per il
diritto d'autore in una tassa ora tutto
questo non ha ragione di esistere
da un punto di vista tecnico non c'è
ragione
da un punto di vista tecnico è possibile
per qualsiasi utilizzazione ripartire
questi compensi in maniera facile e
veloce e trasparente possibile
monitorare ogni singolo utilizzo dei
brani in qualsiasi utilizzazione e dare
una rendicontazione praticamente in
tempo reale in tempo reale in cui un
qualsiasi utilizzatore un qualsiasi
avente diritto può andare sul suo
account laner vedere la
la musica è stata suonata a roma
stoccolma a perugia cioè francamente è
un settore dove l'innovazione
tecnologica potrebbe cambiare
completamente la sorte degli autori
editori perché noi non dobbiamo pensare
a quello autore editore mega star
noi dobbiamo pensare a quella autore
editore che ogni anno fa 20 25 30 35
mila euro quella fascia media che fa
difficoltà bene a quella fascia media 5
mila euro più 10 mila euro in più
cambiano la vita e quindi una
ripartizione in maniera analitica una
capacità di vedere i suoi compensi dove
sono gli cambierebbe la vita vi faccio
capire in un con uno schema abbastanza
semplice perché una questione diciamo
soltanto tecnologiche non è una
questione diciamo giuridica non è una
questa è una questione di tecnologia di
efficienza del processo
noi abbiamo degli autori che
sostanzialmente licenziano attraversano
queste società utilizzatori
professionisti poi si dovrebbe fare
l'analisi di ciò che è stato suonato e
pagare le royalties non è fantascienza
non è il culo la cura per il cancro è
qualcosa di assolutamente possibile e
perché non si è fatto allora perché
perché i monopoli non favoriscono
l'innovazione e non permettono
fondamentalmente ad altri di emergere
e allora l'europa a un certo punto ha
deciso di voltare pagina nel 2008 decide
attraverso la decisione cisa che ogni
autore editore si può iscrivere alla
società che desidera in europa e non si
ferma qua perchè nel 2014
a febbraio 2014 liberalizza per sempre
in tutto il territorio europeo
il mercato del diritto d'autore e dice
con molta semplicità e chiarezza questa
direttiva la direttiva barbier dice tre
cose
ogni autore editore libero di iscriversi
alla società che è meglio preferisce in
europa
ogni autore editore è libero di
assegnare differenti classi di diritti a
differenti società e ogni utilizzatore
compra dove vuole il mercato è libero
fondamentalmente e lo dice con grande
chiarezza ma d'altronde come si fa
pensare che in europa nello spazio
dell'europa unita non si possa fare
concorrenza da una nazione all'altra e
allora adesso in italia sarebbe proprio
il caso di cambiare questo monopolio ma
che cosa succede in italia nel frattempo
fedez si disse iscrivere alla siae una
settimana fa
la carrà e ligabue dicono che vogliono
la liberalizzazione 300 innovatori e di
imprenditori scrivono al premier renzi
per la liberalizzazione
una campagna che parte dal basso
franceschini ripensa ci invade web tutti
i partiti propongono emendamenti per la
liberalizzazione il ministro
franceschini dice io voglio il monopolio
staremo a vedere che cosa succede
grazie grazie